not that long ago you and I took a trip
together to South Korea and you showed
me
Seoul you showed me the just wonderful
places we had great adventures I'm
curious I know you've been back a lot
since have you found any places that you
if I went again that you would take me
to that you think I just have to see
yeah you would love Korea this time
around I've been back a couple times and
I got a lay of the land
there's like a you know I have this
great bar that you would be like right
in there it's like uh this transvestite
bar where they why does my name pop up
not that I have a problem with it I'm
just some things you see transvestite on
your like Conan he's gotta be in it it's
because it's like so chill in there
everybody's so non judgey everybody's
open loving just warm and you go in
there and you watch these beautiful
transvestites do their thing and it's
like and you have a beer it's the
greatest yeah I think you would love it
okay let's go I would go there okay I
will go there I go there every year yeah
that was just an oddly timed coffee well
is that just me it was just an Aussie
parasite that it was a parasite yeah
it's coming out this way Mike you don't
wanna go down there listen let's try and
clean this up a little bit so I will go
there with ya things do that
you